since failure is not an option
we need to figure out what to do next
and we will try to do this by learning a
little bit of biology and biology will
give us a hint on how we should
implement our algorithm some of you may
find description of somewhat convoluted
biological concepts that I am about to
present difficult to digest if you feel
like this don't worry if you believe me
that DNA replication is an isometric
process then you can simply skip this
part and go to the point when v0i from
this biological knowledge how to design
efficient algorithm to remind ourselves
is that DNA strands have directions and
the two strands of DNA run in opposite
direction here on this slide the blue
strand runs clockwise and the green
strand runs counterclockwise and if you
were a DNA polymerase
how would you replicate a genome if I
was a DNA polymerase I would do
something very simple I would wait until
DNA unwind a little bit
recruit for DNA polymerases and we'll
just move them along the genome trying
to replicate it it looks like just for
DNA polymerases enough to replicate the
whole genome and when replication fork
and logic continue and continue my
replica is the replication process this
is simple but completely wrong and if
the raw biology professors attending
this lecture
they are probably already writing a
petition to fire me and send me to
biology 101 camp the reason why it
doesn't work is that DNA polymerases are
uni-directional
they can only
kappa DNA in the direction that is
opposite to the direction of DNA which
means that when we want to recruit for
polymerizes to replicate DNA two of them
this one and this one will be working
just fine
but two others won't be able to move
because they cannot move in the same
direction as the direction of DNA then
they can classify DNA strand in strands
into four half-strands the strands that
i showed you the blue strands that goes
from origin to terminus is the reverse
half strand and I have no problem
replicated it because moving from origin
to terminus goes in the opposite
direction to DNA likewise this seek
green lines that I show right now easels
also doesn't present any problem
replicated one DNA polymerase can
accomplish it but to other half strands
present big big problem because they
cannot move in the same direction that
they go so if you were a unidirectional
DNA polymerase
how would you replicate a genome here's
a potential solution wait until fork
enlarges and when it will not start
replicating it in the opposite in in the
same direction as DNA then fork enlarges
a little bit more you put another DNA
polymerase and continue replicated for
DNA polymerase this won't be enough
because each of these DNA polymerases
that I recruited copy just approximately
3,000 nucleotides so you may need huge
number of DNA polymerases to proceed
this way you can see that the resulting
fragments this many fragments that are
being built called Okazaki fragments
complicate our life a little bit but in
the end after this process is over they
will have many akasaki fragments so we
will have genome
carpet in many many little fragments and
zone isn't we need afterwards is just to
repair the gaps between different
akazake fragments and to replicate the
gym so the only thing we need to learn
about this process to proceed with is
our algorithm afterwards is that reverse
and forward half strands so sick half
strands and seen half strands have very
different lifetime the reverse
half-strands leaves a double stranded
life because it constantly replicated
there is hardly moment when it leaves
double stranded but the forward half
strands spend a large portion of its
life single-stranded because it has to
wait until replication forks open until
it starts replication this is I hope
this is clear but there is one looming
question why would a computer scientist
care and we will learn in the next
segment why computer scientists should
care about this
so asymmetry of replication affect
nucleotide frequencies why let's think
about this single-stranded DNA has a
much higher mutation rate than double
stranded daily that's why if one
nucleotide has a great mutation rate
then we should observe a shortage of
this nucleotide on the forward half
strand because it's fans single-stranded
life of each nucleotide a t c oj has the
higher mutation rate and why it turn out
that there is a peculiar statistics of
mutation rates of nucleotides and
cytosine C rapid limitate into T what is
quite amazing is that through this daya
mediation process rate of mutation rise
hundredfold
when DN is
Ingle stranded which means that the
strands that leaves single-stranded life
very quickly get depleted from see what
does it mean for us as algorithm
designers forward five strands that
leave single-stranded life has shortage
of C and normal G reviewers have strands
that leave double stranded life have
shortage of G and normalcy now keeping
this in mind let's take a walk along the
genome we started terminus and let's say
we move from terminus according to the
red line to origin in this case we move
along the Strand at which there is C is
high and G slow which means that G minus
C is decreasing as we walk right but
when we walk along this half strand on
this cap strand sees low mg is high
which means G minus C total number of
nucleotides G minus total number of
nucleotides C is increasing as we walk
again this sounds like peculiar and not
very important think why do we care I
ask one more question if you walk along
a genome and you see and you count
number of G and number of C's that use -
number of C's that you saw and you have
be seen that number of G - number of C
have been decreasing and then suddenly
start increasing imagine just imagine
you walk through the genome you count
the difference G - C and it has been
decreasing concerned suddenly start
increasing my question is where in the
genome aisle and to figure out where in
the genome and figure out where in the
genome are you we need once again to
look at peculiar statistics the only
place in the genome where behavior of G
- C switches from decreasing to
increasing is origin of replication
which means that
you walk along the genome and see that G
minus C has been decreasing concern
suddenly start increasing it means you
just passed the original replication and
this is a hint for our algorithm